hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast the art of war unleashing the
immune system to fight cancer and Brenda
Kelly Kim elaborate on your moderator
for today's event we are delighted to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
athlete metrics a few metrics a part of
thermo fisher scientific is a pioneer in
microarray technology and a leader in
genomic analysis affymetrix develops and
provides innovative technology that will
enable multiplex and parallel analysis
of biological systems of the cell
protein and gene level facilitating the
rapid translation of results into
biology for a better world our extensive
portfolio of translational and clinical
solutions enable scientists and
clinicians to rapidly translate their
research into understanding underlying
disease mechanisms identifying
biomarkers for personalized medicine
creating novel molecular diagnostic
tests and improving genetic marker
assisted breeding programs in
agriculture for human health and
wellness we strive to provide leadership
and support partnered with our customers
and their quest to translate biological
knowledge into clinical application and
routine use we are proud to be part of
the thermo fisher scientific family
helping to advance our mission to enable
our customers to make the world
healthier cleaner and safer for more
information please visit WWE tix com we
have a few important announcements
before we begin this webcast is designed
to be interactive and may encourage you
to ask questions during the event you
can submit your questions by typing them
in the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll try to answer as many of your
questions as we can today we can enlarge
the slide window by clicking on the
screen icon at the lower right the
presentation Linda if you have any
problems viewing or hearing this present
asian please click on a support button
top right of your presentation window or
submit your problem through the green
Q&A button lower left I would now like
to introduce today's speaker dr. John
Connolly dr. Connolly is a senior
principal investigator and director for
translational immunology at the
institute of molecular and cellular
biology additionally dr. Connolly serves
as program director we a star program
and translational research and
infectious disease a multidisciplinary
center but focused on vaccine
development as a human immunologist his
research focuses on immuno therapy for
cancer and target discovery for immune
modulation dr. Connolly is adjunct
associate professor of analogy at Baylor
University we received his PhD in
immunology from Dartmouth Medical School
and studied human dendritic cell biology
under dr. Michael Fanga during his time
he was involved in the development of
immunotherapeutic preclinical models and
clinical trials for glioblastoma
multiforme a he moved to the Baylor
Institute for immunology research a
fully translational research institute
dedicated to rationally designed
biologics vaccines and cell therapy for
cancer dr. Connolly served as the
director of research initiatives for the
Baylor research institute a large
integrated translational research
research resource and
multi-institutional programs that
involved a number of international sites
during his tenure at bailon dr. Connelly
was a central core facility director the
niaid centers for translational research
on human in technology and biodefense an
nih-funded consortium the basic
translational research and clinical
trials focused on vaccine design dr.
Connelly is the past president of the
board of directors of the American
Cancer Society in North Texas and
founding director of the Singapore
immunology network on Mount terminal for
dr. to dr. Connelly for his presentation
okay great thank you very much for that
introduction and thank you all for for
being here today good morning to
everyone in the US and good evening to
all my colleagues here in Asia so my
name is John Connolly as you just heard
and it's really quite an opportunity for
me to to talk to you guys today I'm
really excited to speak about our work
in immuno therapy for cancer and I'd
like to during the next hour so
highlight some of the work that we've
done in early on both when we were in
New Hampshire and in Texas and then here
in Singapore and talk a little bit about
some of the fundamental research that
went into the design of some of our
union of therapies but also to highlight
some of the really important fundamental
discoveries that are being made
throughout the field of immuno therapy
for cancer and some of the fantastic
work that's being done by other labs in
spaces like biologics and hopefully by
the end of this you'll have a context in
which not just to understand these
results but also in which to sort of
understand how we're moving forward what
the biggest challenges are here in this
field of cancer med therapy and how we
can begin to use the immune system to to
fight cancer so I think that this is a
this is an area I think you're all aware
of it that's really picked up enormous
amounts of speed in the last five or six
years and it's been both in the
scientific press as well as in the
popular press is a really important
breakthrough in our fields of cancer is
the application of the immune system to
attacking the tumors and this is based
really on just wildly successful results
some incredible breakthroughs
paradigm-shifting graters with these
discoveries and this medical application
is really based on a newly based on
decades of research that has been done
not directed you know cancer but really
directed trying to fundamentally
understand what is happening in the
immune system how union system function
in terms of trying to direct you know
responses to invading pathogens and so
those fundamental discoveries have
really led to our understanding and
application toward the fields of
Medicine so just stepping vectors for a
second to talk about how we approach
things so my group so is referred from
the introduction I my lab studies
fundamental human immunology and I had
the good fortune of working with some
spectacular human immunologist
throughout my training and the what they
really drilled in is really to
understand the human immune system you
really have to study humans and so to do
that we really analyze a lot of ongoing
clinical trials both our own
investigator-initiated trials as well as
large phase 1 2 and 3 clinical trials to
try to get a better understanding of the
human immune response during the course
of disease and therapy and so in essence
this is really a truly experimental
medicine that we're working with and to
approach this we put together a program
and translational analogy tries to
address the gaps between laboratory
medicine and clinical practice and so
the first important areas we look at
clinical support so trying to create
relational databases to understand our
clinical data organized it research
nurse staff to try to to handle sample
acquisition bio banking capability is
critical so being able to particular
large cohorts of human samples in order
to get high-quality data from these
cohorts and build quite an extensive
biobank in these trials and then I think
an important part of this as well is the
application of technology advanced
technology and so in this we put
together an immuno monitoring platform
and you're watching platforms really an
assortment of cell-based core facilities
technology-focused cords and a common IT
infrastructure that can integrate that
data together so these three pillars
really form the crux of the program that
gives us real information about
mechanisms of action so actually how are
these therapies working in
divisions they work for and you know
probably more importantly how do they
fail you know what is the mechanism of
resistance Tamia therapy and this is
something we spend an enormous amount of
time talking about an understanding with
the eventual hope and actually in some
cases we've actually died understanding
this mechanism and then rationally
redesigning our therapy to make the
image that we more effective across the
products that you move individuals so
this is really kind of the greater
vision and how we propose things since
since they want in the studies so let's
take a mother step back to talk about
you know the application again of these
fundamental discoveries to cancer and to
do that we really want to get a better
interesting of how science in general is
to ribbon and I think that if someone
can come up with more than that would be
great but in my mind I think we really
it's um by three different things so
first is it's luck which I equate with
hard work and so individuals that are
working and doing the same thing over
and over again you have a certain level
of expectation in your experimental
studies and when something comes up
different you really go back and
investigate that and so this is this is
really where you make some very
important discoveries this is
exemplified by by the discovery of
penicillin where you really see these
these differences in this teaches you
something completely different about
what we do the other is is genius and in
this sense there are some people are
just born this there's something wrong
with them yeah so they just see the
universe differently and in doing so
science leaps forward with their revised
understanding and so these are these are
of course people like Darwin and
Einstein it and called Iraq were they
they see these kind of differences in it
revolutions of things but the main
driver of scientific advance and
certainly the one that I think most
applies to work in that will be talking
about today is the advent of new
technology so a telescope was invented
and Galileo can study the moon Cook has
a microscope when we have a germ theory
of disease so these kind of advances in
the acceleration of technology in the
past 50 years and particularly in the
past 20 years has really driven a lot of
these discoveries and given us a much
better understanding of what is
fundamentally an extremely complex
system that it's the immune system so so
with these discoveries though I think
it's natural and it's certainly natural
for any human immunologist to try to
then drive medical advance so science
does in turn drive medicine and these
discoveries are applied to hopefully
improving the overall human condition
and so this is certainly true in the
context of the immune response where we
have numerous examples where our
understanding of the immune system or at
least the application at immune system
whether we understand it or not has led
to really wonderful advances so one of
the first understands that we have an
immune system you think about it is
we've divided into an adaptive immune
response and innate and adaptive immune
response so the innate immune response
is really suit the physical barriers and
there we quickly reacted cells
neutrophils monocytes the non antigen
specific responses that happen in the
rapid physical defense and these really
make up the bulk of most of your
protective capability the other response
that I think that most people would
equate with proper immune function is
this concept that the adaptive immune
response and this is to provide by
immunological membrane so what this is
is really when when an organism invades
and you're my chromosomes attacks you
you have a specialized selective memory
cells that are selected for it expanded
this leads to a greater preponderance of
these specialized cells in a secondary
infection so which basically works like
memory so that you're sort of reactive
to the secondary response and so this we
of course call the adaptive immune
response accuse the immune buddy the new
system is essentially prepared for the
secondary attack now although we all
think of this is is clearly a normal
functioning in system and something that
we all understand realistically it's not
it's not actually normally it's not
something that we see throughout life
it's really only jawed vertebrates and
and very few other organisms there's
some wonderful work from that next next
Cooper and others looking at lamprey
eels that have convergently evolved this
but realistically it's just us that the
jawed vertebrates that
develop this adaptive immune response
but despite not really even
understanding you know how this
dysfunction for many years we were still
able to leverage the potency and power
of this adaptive immune response to
treat human disease so very early on it
was identified that Athenian plague
victims even in ancient Greece who
survived the plague could then you know
without risk to themselves and then
treat treat existing patients and so we
now know that this is this is the
product of this immunological memory
that's giving him protection and some
years later we had the work of Edward
Jenner whose observations of milk maids
who had been exposed to Kyle parked
within protecting in smallpox in and
generous famous experiments taking a boy
and actually infecting him with vaccinia
virus the cow pox and exposing them to
to smallpox demonstrated very clearly
that this is a this is mechanistically
how you are actually protected and that
there's this cross protection between
these two viral strains obviously
something that we would do today we
classify as experimental medicine but it
was certainly quite definitive so this
even though we at the time we didn't
have a very good theoretical framework
in which i understand immune system we
were still applying it and this has led
to what was it arguably the greatest
success of immunology certainly
vaccinology which is a development of
vaccines is leverages this adaptive
immune response to really treat human
human maladies and if you look here
there's a number of figures that are out
there like this all of them are equally
impressive when you look at the the
Roman vaccines and protecting us against
what is the scourge of the human race in
the context of infectious disease in a
single century we essentially greatly
eliminated these these things from
problems and this is really the
development of obviously vaccines it
culminates with probably one of the
greatest advances in all of medicine
which is the eradication of smallpox in
the late nineteen
knees so this is fantastic even without
understanding the deputy in system
you're still able to leverage it to
develop these vaccines but in order to
rationally design therapies for
something it's difficult as cancer we
needed a theoretical framework English
to understand it and so very early on it
was recognized that they are specialized
cells in the immune system that they're
dynamic they Crossley communicate with
each other they polarized there's a
kinetic nature to these cells I already
mentioned that this immunologic memory
something extremely complex and so how
how do we start how do we approach this
so that we can then some you know
experimentally address this and begin to
manipulate and utilize it to treat treat
cancer well I think that in the past
hundred years and one of the greatest
postulates assert came forward in which
the framework to understand this was
really exemplified by the statement here
which is the scription on the Temple of
Apollo in Delphi and for those of you
can't read Greek it's it's it says know
thyself and so that concept that
statement of know thyself really is a
framework in which we've understood
immunology in in the past hundred years
and so it will fundamental theorem of
immunology and this was best fertilized
by a professor at the College of France
Claude Bernard famous scientists in his
own right for his research a
vivisectionist and anatomist philosopher
a poet and a real proponent of
scientific method it was really his
philosophy and the philosophy that is
the time that led to his his his
statements around it in contradiction to
an animal which is in humoral balance in
the universe really the primacy of the
organism is essential to our
understanding of reactions with nature
so he was he was a man of his time in
the sense that he was a humanist it was
man against nature self versus non-self
became this context in which he was
describing his contemporaries
experiments in immunology although this
was a fantastic postulant it lacked
evidence so and although it
normal theoretical framework that was in
certain keeping with the Industrial
Revolution and its management of his
time in the period and so the
theoretical contracts in wish
understanding analogy was this concept
of protected self services the central
theme that an entity is identified as
self is protected actively and then
identify its non self is actively
attacked and so that really became this
understanding of how the immune system
could possibly function although it's it
you know it was used and understood to
look at the work of pastoral and ehrlich
and then there's other people it really
wasn't until but in 1950s that we began
to actually see molecular evidence of
this of this actually holding up and
this came from the work of transplant
surgeons who were trying to understand
why transplanted organs were accepted
versus not accepted and in doing so
essentially identified the molecular
nature of self and so it was known that
you could transplant organs between
identical twins with some level of
success and and that there was something
about genetically ingrained that
recognized his self and that by the
1950s the human major histocompatibility
antigens of MHC molecules were theatre
serologically identified in his
molecules in all of us are the most
diverse regions of the genome and
because of this they really service in
essence molecular signatures of self
okay so this is this is fantastic and it
supports the overall hypothesis of self
versus non-self being how the immune
system functions and I should say that
throughout this time there are competing
hypotheses that were out there but this
one has stood the test of time
particularly when we began to read us to
get the questions of non-self so there
are we all know there are many cases in
which the immune system doesn't react to
the lack of self and therefore it was
hypothesized that there must be for this
possible this theorem can be true there
must be a molecular mechanism non-self
recognition and it took a really long
time for us to begin to then recognize
this but these are these markers of
non-self to exist in nature and so they
pathogens have a number of different
molecular patterns so things that they
really can't change theirs they're like
themselves like viruses like bacteria
but completely unlike everything else
that's in humanity we call these
patterns molecular pattern Patrick
pathogen-associated molecular patterns
or pamps and so these are signatures
that these are proteins or these are
lipids or molecules that are very
difficult for the organism to change but
and they're very well conserved across a
broad category of species but they are
there's something that they can't change
so we're able to then recognize these
and they represent invariant or
minimally variant markers of non-self so
these are targets potentially for
receptors to recognize but it wasn't
really until before only 1990s early mid
1990s that the peace tree gentleman
along with their teams and labs and a
number of other individuals but really
went out and pioneered and identified
these molecular sieves receptors
germline encoded receptors have been
recognized non-self molecules and so
this is a work of Charles Janeway Bruce
coiler and Jules Hoffman who identified
these toll-like receptor system that can
recognize myself and is one of them one
of the major non-self recognition
systems that are out there right now and
so the tlr system can recognize these
pants these molecular patterns that can
see virus-specific patterns you can see
bacterial specific or fungus specific
and identified them as non-self and
therefore initiate an immune response
against these molecules importantly it's
not just the recognition of these you
know single organisms the coordinated
expression and combined combinatorial
signaling between these receptors allows
you to tailor your responses against
these packages so that you can have a
diversity of specialized responses that
are directed to deal with different
kinds of organisms like gram-negative
gram-positive flagellated bacteria
viruses etc and so this these this
system and it does typify a number of
other non-self recognition
but it it initiates the overall response
important in the magnitude and quality
response is determined by the actual
camps that are expressed and the context
in which they recognized that important
ly the combinatorial signals determine
how the downstream seems like polarized
now this is a fantastic model we've now
sort of validated what what collabera
dart said that we found in molecular
nature itself a molecular injured
non-self and this gives us some kind of
real molecular and evidential context in
which to understand overall immune
responses but one one question that came
about was one of the key cells in this
immune system in this organism that made
this decision so they're all cells due
to their specialized cells and that
initiate this recognition and decision
of non-self to self and initiate an
immune response and so it was the work
of of this gentleman here sir Ross
diamond who in the early 1970s was
working at the Rockefeller University in
Zen koans lab and identified a cell type
that was remarkably good in initiating
and priming new immune responses and
respond you know with particularly with
non-self pattern recognition and so
these cells are of course dendritic
cells and so the cells are extremely
good at initiating new primed responses
in taking these molecular patterns which
are essentially innate immune
recognition and converting them and
using them to instruct the development
of an adaptive immune response so quite
critical cells in overall immunity and
so that's really what these dendritic
cells do so for instance a tender Excel
can serve as a sentinel constantly
tasting and internalizing proteins or
fluid or dead cell debris and in this
case I can identify and internalize the
flu virus for instance process that
virus and then present the virus to t
cells now it's not just the recognition
and presentation of not sell it is
transmitting signals to instruct those T
cells to become specialized antiviral T
cells and so as we're learning it from
the work of Ralph and and jack10 and
until now let's make it many many other
than things and drink cell biologists
are out there exactly how this works
we're beginning to understand how we
might be able to manipulate this you
know to generate specific kinds of t
cell responses in to leverage our
understanding of this time to excel
system so the dendritic cells i
mentioned sits in the periphery so it's
in your tissue and it's constantly
internalizing like a sentinel drinking
the the eating dead cell debris and
drinking it the milieu and asking if a
cell dies why did you die did you die
naturally are you self or did you die do
the viral infection or bacterial
infection how you do have a non self
component and if it recognizes that it
induces this maturation sigma that is
qualitatively determined by the kind of
pathogen encountered so if the virus
signal that polarizes it one way if it's
a bacterial signal a polarizing than
other so the dendrites all been migrated
to the local lymph node where it can
then interact with T cells and then
instruct those T cells to become in this
case antiviral and then migrate out to
the periphery and the t-cells
importantly are the effectors the guys
that are actually doing the killing and
destroying infected cells so our
fundamental understanding of how to
initiate these immune responses it was
quite a critical breakthrough and still
is so I'll show you a movie here just
sort of demonstrate I think we dendritic
cells it's it's important to sort of see
what they do in order to understand so I
mentioned that they are there sentinels
so I think I'll just press go
you
you
okay so I think hopefully okay so
hopefully you guys saw what those
dendritic cells were doing here in the
movie they're really internalizing this
in this case protein antigen and digital
debris they're constantly reaching out
and constantly internalizing and in
doing so they really are taking up a
number of you know molecules and they're
tasting these molecules and asking again
why did you die so I think the next
slide demonstrates the same kind of
thing wit but in this case we're looking
at the internalization of dead cell
debris and in this so hopefully you'll
see that in the next one
you
so what you can see is it they have a
huge affinity for extracellular vesicles
and dead cells debris they're constantly
internalizing that and as I said they're
diagnosing why did you die what kind of
infection leg you deaf or was this a
natural antibiotic cell death which
would lead to a differential maturation
program of those dc's inducing house of
times and so I think in the next slide
we'll just complete these movies to sort
of show you what it looks like when you
see non-self recognition so this is
these are dendritic cells primary human
dendritic cells from from my blood
actually so it's about four hours fresh
post blood looking at a colony of e.coli
and asking about pattern recognition
you
okay great so I think what you guys saw
there is that they got real excited by
the presence of a colony of e.coli and
this is something that that naturally
happens of course when you see this
pattern recognition so we didn't see me
though was during that process the
secretion of a wide variety of
chemokines calling in different levels
of specialized cells that would be
specific for for bacterial infection so
waves of neutrophils monocytes and
polarize t-cells to be attracted to deal
with that infection so directing from an
adaptive neutrons directing with the
innate immune response and that's not
true for all dendritic cells so here's
an example of a plasma site to a DC from
the same experiment these cells have
specialized to deal with viruses and in
fact don't react to any of the the
actual ecoli colony however I think that
you can see here that upon exposure to
virus so in the absolute virus they look
basically like small round cells post
virus infection this is after a few days
of viral infection you see massive
dendrites sprouting they become
extremely active and internalized degree
so they look very much like activated or
attend hritik cells and then very cells
are the work can actually communicate
with each other and through these sort
of microtubular structures and our
understanding of that and how it relates
then to their communication say in the
tumor microenvironment is just now being
understood okay so what we know is that
the dendritic cells and subsets of
dendritic cells can instruct T cells
within the immune response so not just
diagnose the currently infection the
presence of non zone but polarize that
not so responsive to non-self so if you
can get these specialized cells that
could potentially kill virus-infected
cells or potentially infected kill tumor
cells so we know that the dcs are
composed of multiple specialists subsets
the express our own TLRs they're
extremely efficient using immune
response and they can distinguish
between self and non-self and dictate
response so can we use them to treat
disease so very early on during this
process
and some of the early cell therapy
studies we started taking candle use
this very important cells to initiate
anti to neural responses and so I guess
out of all of the possible utilizations
of these cells cancer is one of the
hardest and most difficult ones because
as we talked about using clods postulant
this cancer is really a happily growing
part of you so it's it should be
actually protect itself right so and
this is exactly in many cases exactly
what we see the cancer is protected by
the immune system actively protected and
in a dominant immune tolerate any way
and it's very difficult to generate some
of these responses and so I think when
we start talking about immunotherapy for
cancer it would be remiss not to go back
to really the links of the first
application of immunotherapy for cancer
which was what's way back during that
time period one when clogged and telling
the hallways immunology materials I
mentioned has to be really Ehrlich in
these guys with just now figuring out
what these immune cells did it was
really to work that really poorly in the
late 1800s and early 1900s who after
really looking at a sarcoma surgeon at
the Memorial Hospital in New York City
really started looking at why people
were surviving sir here and not
surviving surgery and went about him and
tried to find anecdotal evidence or any
kind of evidence that would indicate why
some people stopping one of the things
he noted was that there was an occasion
and on some occasions people got
post-surgical directions which happened
it happens even now but certainly more
often during that time period and that
in at least one individual this post
surgical infection led to a sub what
looked like a clinical remission that
outlasted the actual infection itself
and so this led him to begin to
hypothesize that in fact the immune
response against the bacteria it was
somehow leading to a response against
the tumor and so this was a you know
quite quite interesting so he began by
actually infecting people with with
bacteria and this led to predictably
poor outcomes so massive fever real
infections obviously some deaths he then
went back and really get to devise
combinations of bacterial isolates and
toxins and put together this cold eeze
toxin which also of course was full of
toll-like receptor agonist and
stimulating non-self in the context of
the tumor led to huge fevers real
illness in sickness and was very
difficult to watch and look at but in
some cases actually did induce very
impressive responses in individuals but
these responses were unpredictable and
they had you know telling the terrible
side effects and so much of the horror
of some his contemporaries and one of
those contemporaries was was as many
people i know he's James Ewing of Ewing
sarcoma theme so he's he's really a
physician scientist this guy very bright
guy a true champion of this new field of
radiotherapy that was coming at that
time and and pulled in it would help of
some of his friends and and colleagues
rhenium into into Memorial enormous
amount radium through serious friends of
Douglas and mining barons and these guys
and so he brought this in and really
champion radiation therapy as a new
field and this was really in contrast to
immunotherapy that's going on so this
led to some difficult times between the
leadership there at the memorial and
then later on with the introduction of
advanced chemotherapy immunotherapy
really kind of didn't really fit within
this dominant paradigm and so by 1955
the Chloe's toxins that memorial was
stopped that they were seen as an
unproven mechanism that wasn't solid
scientific evidence it really wasn't
until many years later through cancer
research institution and a number of
other champions world and many fantastic
scientists poet and his daughter but
codes are putting together a number of
studies to really look at the impact of
these kohli toxins so it really wasn't
until much much later that we saw Lisa
these toll-like receptor agonist
stimulating
a tumor immunity and it really was
nearly a hundred years before we saw the
same levels of responses in sarcoma so
the advantage i mentioned that and i
think it's obvious that the cancer is a
happily growing part you so the cancer
the immune system really needs a
football to grab on to it in order to
see the cancer and what it sees is
really the mistakes of the cancer makes
the altar itself so the immune response
is really only initiated when when the
cancer cell begins to make some of these
mistakes and so one of the questions
that your vases can we build on what
curlies toxin was doing so present these
mistakes these mutations or these
metabolic differences in the context of
non-self by using by using stimulatory
toxins like protons toxin and so these
these mistakes that account to make some
of the most important of which are
called neo antigen certain or simply
mutations that arise as a consequence of
tumor specific events like rapid growth
or p53 loss and mutagenesis and so
they're really recognized as the major
target of anti-tumor immunity
particularly t-cell immunity and so
there are a number of novel therapeutic
approaches that are being developed by
like Schreiber scrutiny and many many
other groups that are out there to
leverage these neo antigen responses so
what are the downsides about this is
that these new entities are not
universal throughout the tumor as the
tumor progresses and builds different
regions of the tumor accumulate
different levels of antigen so you might
get an immune response against some of
the tumor but but the rest of the tumor
has you know different types of
mutations so we need to really address
this heterogeneity and come up with a
macaroon so one mechanism very early on
that that we try to try to approach is
really utilizing dendritic cells to do
to actually present these new antigens
and overexpressed tumor antigens and so
in this case it's an example of some of
our melanoma clinical trials in Texas
under the leadership of Jacques and
Carolina and with Joe fatally position
we isolated dendritic cells who are
isolated from blood or monocytes to
derive these dendritic cells
we loaded them leave that cancer
proteins of some of these neo antigens
and then activated them and inject them
back into the patients and so reading to
them it a t-cell response within the
tumor so within the lymph node so the T
cells now are being trained contextually
that this is non self that you're seeing
to really divide and to to rev up the
anti 200 meters box they'll then
migrated periphery where they could then
they could then destroy the tumor at the
sites and so this is some of the DC
vaccines that we ran so not a Noma trial
you can see the gp100 protein in red
inside the dendritic cell so he sees
were vaccine itself is you that is the
vaccine itself you can see it
internalizes these and has the ability
than to present these antigens to t
cells and initiate strong immune
responses i think that the you know once
they're in there they migrate not just
to the drain limp no but you can find
dendritic cells actually in the tumor
sites themselves which is which is good
it brings you be then taking up other
tumor antigens presumably and cross
presenting those and expanding the
breadth of anti-tumor immunity I think
that this this data typifies a lot of
the research that's done by not just the
Baylor Institute's team but our team but
also the group our own ongoing research
now and dendritic cell vaccines the
fantastic research from the livery
consortium as well as a huge number of
groups doing dendritic cell vaccines for
for a number of years and that was that
when tumors when you see a clinical
benefit this is coincident with an
immune response but if you don't see
this immune response that if you don't
see new response then you really don't
see the clinical benefit and this is
some examples of the kind of clinical
benefit that that's there that we see
and the reason I put your missing in the
next slide is really the unlikely no
therapy you you can see when you do see
a response oftentimes the response is
actually amazing and quite strong so you
see the biopsy the subcutaneous melanoma
nodules and then biopsy negative poles
melanin and then in the context of this
I'm not sure if you guys can see the
pointer but in the context of the
baseline chemo creating immunotherapy
the large peritoneal mass that's
pressing up against a kidney after eight
vaccines this is now a fibrous tissue
and then large lung metastases here
which you're eliminated post therapy so
this one of the difference between
immunotherapy chemotherapy is really
this when you do see response is a
dramatic response and oftentimes very
durable response so there are a lot of
dendritic cells that you can use right I
mentioned that there are specialized
cells and so one of the dendritic cells
that we can look at is are some of these
plasma side to idc's or are the Chinamen
degree cells another is trying to take
advantage of the receptors or on a
surface in dcs and actually targeting
those receptors so can we instead of
taking the cells out can you bring the
antigen air doing deliverable a
stimulatory signal and tumor antigen and
so it'll work this is working given
collaboration with metrics and subjects
to develop some of these targeting
reagents we've also worked with the
girard zorroski and his team as well
doing spectacular targeting research so
really what this is looking at it's
trying to develop antigen target so
single protein antibodies have been
dragged along tumor antigens and so we
can get these antigens to target
dendritic cells you can see here that in
a time course they're internalized
within the dendritic cell and they are
then processed and presented they need
to strong t-cell unity which you can see
here this is this is looking at
cytolytic activity against tumor targets
induced by targeted cells and so we can
deliver these kind of reagents so one
key question is what kind of cells do we
want to target and so there are a number
of cell types that we can go for one
could potentially be some of these
plasma site or dendritic cells but also
plasma site to a DC subsets that we've
demonstrated previously that is a CD to
positive subset that appears to kill the
tumor itself and so this could be a
really potentially phenomenal target to
begin to
engine particularly with our better
understanding of how to polarize these
cells 20 th why I'm hearing and so in
essence i think the in a monitoring that
came out of these studies / / are
working as well as others really came up
with a few different things one is if
you don't see an immune response you
really don't you get progression on
trial some people you do see an immune
response but we lose that immune
response in time which leads to disease
progression in depth and then in other
individuals in a small subset of
individuals on these vaccine trials but
very consistent we see very strong
immune responses that are coincident
with durable response an excellent
survival and so the key really is to
study to study all these people but to
really go after those individuals that
we can induce a response against but
it's not maintained and to ask what is
it about this response that's
fundamentally different between response
between these individuals that can't
maintain response and those that do so
what is the mechanism of resistance to
our immunotherapy okay so one of the
things that we identify and was really
and it's reflected in other vax trials
that were out there is the harder we hit
these individuals with dendritic cells
and the more stimulatory these disease
were the heart of the immune system push
back so there's this reflexive push back
and to sort of prevent over stimulation
of the immune response and this this is
a multi-faceted system of resistance and
its regulatory t-cells it's mild address
suppressor cells it's a number of
different factors but one of the most
important factors in the way the immune
system resists over stimulation is
immune checkpoints and so the Union
checkpoint system which you may have
heard of really is a built-in system in
the immune response that that avoids
overstimulation so it's really developed
to for a number of different reasons one
of course is to develop chronic
stimulation of the TT seller answered
presenting cell system and so Clive
simulation leads to a variety of the
expression variety hibbett or receptors
on the t cell surface these inhibitory
receptors
essentially our item containing
receptors that dephosphorylate key
signaling molecules within the T cell
and this leads to functional exhaustion
of the T cells these cells are
non-responsive to secondary therapy
they're terrible killers and it doesn't
really matter if they're tumor specific
or not they're just not going anywhere
yet these receptors are actually engaged
and so I think that this you know due to
the immune selective pressure many
cancers express the ligands for these
receptors and thereby create an
environment that is quite inhibitory to
immune function so they essentially
actively suppress these t-cell responses
and so this has led to the development
of a number of therapeutics it will
target this axis so if we understand how
t cells become exhausted by the tumor
can we develop therapies that can block
this exhaustion and this is something
that is really a hit team in a therapy
field like a bomb and really has been a
major focus for our pharmaceutical
companies out there and a number of
different biotech companies as well and
so the two first molecules that really
hit the market the first was C too late
for work from Jim Allison's group and
with I dick and meh directions and other
companies to develop molecules that will
block this interaction another is this
anti pd-1 ppl one axis and so there's a
difference between these they kind of
acted at different phases immune
response ctla-4 acts at the priming
phase and so this is when the the
t-cells are first being taught by the
dendritic cell what a tumor what the neo
antigen the tumor is there's a strong
signal that leads to the upregulation of
ctla-4 and blocks this co-stimulation
signal by competition and so basically
the ability to generate antitumor
t-cells is limited by the ctla-4
interaction now in the effector phase
you have the role of PB 1 and PDL 1 and
so in this phase what we're seeing is
that the tumor itself can or taller Jack
myeloid cells get up regulate the ligand
of ppl 1episode pd-1 which can then lead
to functional exhaustion so both of
these things working at different
area is really limiting antitumor immune
response and monoclonal antibodies
against them have been shown to be
extremely effective in propagating
antitumor t-cell responses and this is
see here this nature paper looking at
its lung cancer here in this patient
City pretreatment of wide variety of
metastases that are eliminated after
t-cell pd1 to apd one checkpoint in
division and this is coincident with a
massive infiltration of cd8 t-cells
within the tumor itself and when you
actually do the tumor biopsies you can
look at gene expression patterns that
change brush messages are predictably
enriched for cytolytic t-cell molecules
like grandson a grandson beef or
infiltrating that tumor these
reinvigorated t-cells are in there and
they're killing like crazy so this did
not go without notice there's a variety
of companies that have developed
reagents targeting the pd-1 PDL one axis
for the first kind ilysm ab from merck
on trial nivola lab by bristol-myers
squibb against PDL one yervoy and ctla-4
all of them in clinical trials all of
them actually now in clinical practice
for a number of different diseases but
this is really just the beginning so
these three are now available and
they're out there there are other ones
that are other molecules and antibiotic
that are coming onto the market but you
can see there's a wide variety of
activating and inhibitory receptors in
the immune system all of them are
legitimate targets for next generation
therapy and and actually importantly
combinations of these are probably even
give me more effective combinations of
inhibitory molecules or combinations of
activating and inhibitory antibodies
both agonistic and antagonistic so the
combination therapy both in clinical
trials and as I show you here in this
animal model data which demonstrates
this is a tough animal model tumor where
sees only four have some effect over
control pd-1 had anti pd-1 has some
effect but the combination really wipes
wipes out the tumor so you know when you
go back and retrospectively look at the
data sets petite either an animal models
are actually really
human data and you ask which tumors
which cancers are most responsive to to
anti tune look to checkpoint inhibition
and antitumor Amenhotep III check line
addition one of the things that really
came out was that the most mutagenic
tumors like melanoma and run camp
smoking you associate lung cancer once
with lots of mutations are the ones that
respond best to check one in addition
and I get this makes sense right so
there are a lot of Neil antigens that
are present then you can reinvigorate
those t-cells and there's a greater
chance that you can prime that you'll
cross prime T cell responses against it
and then you'll love you know once
preventing the exhaustion you can get
good clinical durable responses and so
this is this is really what people seem
so but it's not enough just have lots of
mutations very recent work from the stem
incenting casado lab has really
identified how these new engines really
do interact with with the immune
response and what's a good new engine
what's a bad new antigen and something
quite a fantastic science paper it
cannot very recently with their really
what they were showing really is it
there's a difference in the quality of
neo antigens so it's not enough just to
induce genotoxic responses against the
tumor and use lots of mutations you
really want to have universally shared
initial identify those trunk mutations
those mutations that are early on the
tree branch and therefore most
universally shared throughout the tumor
these later branch mutations and even
the brands mutations you can induce
cochino toxic therapy like cisplatin
this really actually serves to only
distract the immune response decoy these
many of these T cells away so you really
have very strong a new responses against
the mutations but they're only
representing you know very small
fraction of tumor cells and so the
critical aspects of this are to
understand what the trunk mutations are
these big ones try and stratify these
patients try to induce immune responses
against those trunk mutations and bulk
that up and then come in with people in
therapy or CT for whatever so the the
one could envision a combination
strategy that would include loaded
dendritic cells that through exome
sequencing you've identified these
transportation in combination to in
order to Prime using in respond
you know like a steering wheel when
you're diving respond specifically
toward these computations using DC
vaccines and then maintaining
invigorating these with checkpoint
inhibition and so we're I mean just
tremendously excited to see Sergio and
Charles paper put into action in a
therapeutic sense in the next next five
years hopefully so overall when you look
at the checkpoint inhibitors space that
really great fantastic responses we
twenty thirty percent responses and as
we begin to stratify our patient
populations and perhaps get two
combinations these will go even higher
you see complete remission in a variety
of patients they respond I mentioned the
response depends on the mutational
burden when the more mutations you have
the better and importantly the more of
these trunk mutation responses you get
the better you get but one of the key
aspects of this is that the methods of
resistance is really unknown so we don't
know why some people response and some
people don't and so we really have to
get to the bottom of this and this takes
a lot of you know analysis of these
clinical trials deep immunity no typing
but another approach that the groups
have taken is disabled you know is there
is there something that can be you know
universally done for everybody and
really targeting if we can identify
specific target mutations are tumor
antigens on the surface of these cells
why can't we just go ahead skip all this
stuff and get the t cells to attack them
these are the effectors in the UN
response and so this is where t-cell
immunotherapy comes in so cell therapy
and so we would heavily involved in cell
therapy now in my group here in
Singapore to go after virus driven
cancers in our sin so in this case we're
much like too many cell therapy groups
identified isolating t-cells stick
growing them up in culture to the
antigen specific where we know what the
antigen is and then infusing them back
into the patient so they can go after
and destroy the tumor so in the in the
trial that I'll talk about now this is a
trial for head and neck cancer
nasopharyngeal carcinoma soybean driven
cancer of the nasopharynx we grew up
with very this is in collaboration with
tohon Charlie who's the deputy director
of the National Cancer Center here so we
done is grew up the
be specific t cells and then infuse them
into the patient's we first analyzed
them that the t-cells are not specific
for one tumor antigen or in this case
viral antigen their specific for
aggressive antigen so it's very
difficult to the tune or two to escape
and post infusion we can get very good
by distribution in the patients
including by distribution at the tumor
site itself so within 24 hours we see
what actually with four hours you see
migration into the posterior nasopharynx
and accumulation of these T cells so in
summary we took it was the most
successful trial for nasopharyngeal
carcinoma it gave fantastic durable
responses so we've got now four years
survival on trial but the máquina this
is a overall two years survival 67% it's
better than any other trial it's out
there for npc and it's extremely
encouraging we've now moved this into an
international phase three clinical trial
with 27 sites throughout Asia us so
we're anticipating some purpose and
great responses on the study so overall
the deep enough units have being led us
to identify some some actual mechanisms
of action and resistance so for
mechanism action if you look at the T
cells themselves individuals with strong
t-cell responses against the lmp2
antigen seemed to respond much better
importantly as well youryour systemic
response to infusion also predicted
whether or not you want to survive and
that was if we infuse you with the
t-cells and you responded with this th
one polarized response as reflected by
your plasma proteome this was a very
good prognostic marker you were going to
be okay and there was also a negative
signature associated with non responses
this was associated not with you know
lack of t-cell responses and these
individuals also a t-cell responses of
course because we were abusing a billion
cells but it was actually a reflexive
negative pushback and it was the
cellular push back the expansion of
regular activated regulatory t-cells and
the expansion of these myeloid-derived
suppressor component and so in those
individuals that we're not responding we
saw this real signature and actual
expansion of these myeloid-derived
suppressor population
so this really leads to obviously a
rational redesign of the clinical trial
which we may be in this short time
period are able to eliminate these
myeloid-derived suppressor cells and
precondition you to be more receptive to
email therapy this is true for Arthur
didn't maybe maybe other therapies as
well ok so it's it was you know in the
classics of virus-specific cancers where
the virus is driving the tumor server
NPC that's the case your antigens are
there you go up to the virus antigens
but in the case of many many many tumors
these viruses are either not present
they are not part of the associated
transformation event or they're viruses
aren't there anymore and so you need to
identify something else and so in a
process was taken was really to take
these T cells and actually combine the
power and specificity of monoclonal
antibodies with the effector function of
T cells to you may have heard chimeric
antigen or car t-cell therapy which uses
these monoclonal antibodies
specificities very heavy light chain
variable domains to bind to a particular
tumor antigen combining this in a
genetically engineered construct that
has a signaling domain of the t-cell
receptor so one could engineer a t-cell
there was a fully potent killer but
instead of signaling towards t-cell
receptors it uses this chimeric antigen
receptor to destroy the tumor it
enormous promise on paper and actually
enormous promise of practice to we've
seen this kind of surface finding and
attack so these chimeric recombinant
antigen receptors are actually
destroying the tumor itself and so there
are huge advantages to car therapy one
is that you know kill you the tumor
cells no longer NAC restricted so any
tumor hatches on the surface becomes
your next target it doesn't even have to
be a protein antigen even though after
glycolipids antigens clobber hi gran
antigens you name it if you can make an
antibody against it you can you could
potentially use it for for protein
replica see now there are downsides to
this one is that this is not in inert
t-cell there's signaling
and killing event is intimately linked
to cell division and so these T cells as
they kill they begin to divide and
divide and divide and they're extremely
potent with this very strong signaling
demands that they put on it and so this
can lead to a massive potential for very
high toxicity these toxicity is being
addressed now but we've seen obviously
you've seen some tough times I'm so sort
of side effects on some of these trials
so this is just some example in the
mouse system where different generations
of chimeric antigen receptors can clear
the mouse models in my system but also
more importantly actually in humans
themselves and says this work from our
collaborators see projects lab that at
Baylor College of Medicine looking at
human sarcoma with a her two new cars
it's an antibody answer to new that has
now a chimeric signaling domain
including the cd28 cinnamon and zeta
domain of CP 3 receptor t-cell receptor
and you can see that pre infusion in the
PET scan you can see the tumor mass post
infusion six weeks post infusion you can
see in Linda bringing
immunohistochemistry panel massive
necrotic tissue and an elimination of
that tumor and this is true for a number
of different tumors that people have
tried particularly in the lymphoma space
so we defined is remarkably certain
responses I mean responses that you
never saw on our DC backs trials ninety
percent complete responses in the
context will be sewing promise so the
extreme potency as I mentioned is led to
problems with toxicity and I think more
importantly they associated there's been
limited efficacy so far in the solid
tumor space but there are everyone who's
in this field is worth trying to work on
this problem to try to understand tumor
penetrates so okay it's not just T cells
there's some fantastic groups that are
trying to modify NK cells they have some
advantages in terms of multiple
mechanisms of killing work from Dario
compañías group and
Charles sentence group and others that
are pioneered this NK cell car filled
there's enormous potential for this as
well is so what we're looking forward to
more clinical trials in this space okay
so this looks like a little bit of a
glitch issue but I think you can take
the message home so as much as we can
bring in things like the dendritic cells
to prime you immune responses the
checkpoints that cause these T cells to
become you know not exhausted we can
also envision a situation where we're
maybe we'll be able to come these many
of these things with checkpoint with
genetically engineered T cells with
dendritic cells to crime aggressive
response but I think there are a huge
number of hurdles that are still in
front of us and one of the biggest her
loss is really this tumor
microenvironment so the metabolism of
this environment the acidic micro
environment the ph look like a lip the
cert glycolytic polarization where this
leads all the sugar up so T cells can't
function are really deleterious to
inducing anti-tumor immunity in addition
the metabolic micro environment actually
polarizes myeloid cells become more
tolerant Jenna and this toilet
tolerances it's not passive it's not
just a lack of t-cell responses it
really is dominant immune tolerance and
so they actively present prevent and
polarize and exhaust these T cells and
so this is really the next step in where
we need to go so where are we in terms
of our the next frontier how do we
overcome this dominant tumor
microenvironment so just to finish now
in the last few slides I think that we
have resurrected Claude Bernard in his
room his understanding of the immune
response i think the self non-self
really does serve us well in developing
new therapy for any affecting and i
think to finish on my title and because
we're in asia i think that's a you know
a quote from the art of war itself so if
you know your enemy and know yourself
you need not fear the results are 100
battles so you really need to understand
this concept of myself non-self how to
manipulate it and then apply to admin to
breaking down these natural barriers to
induce strong tumor immunotherapy so
just as a reminder technology drive
science science tries medicine and that
innovation really does occur at this
interface and so I want to thank
everybody for a time and I think there's
a couple of minutes for questions but I
want to make sure that I thank everybody
that helped with this work at the
reflected decades of science and
research particularly hanzhong Jacques
Joe Carolina and Steve and Malcolm
Brenner at Baylor College of Medicine so
thank you guys very much and i think the
moderator will take some questions and
i'm happy to answer him thank you dr.
Connelly great presentation very
important information questions can be
asked by clicking on the green QA button
type in your question into the Q&A box
we'll get right to it since we have
several our first question how do
macrophages differ from dendritic cells
okay okay thanks it's a spectacular
thank you it's a an absolutely fantastic
question and it's an area of
tremendously active research from many
my colleagues but to put it simply
dendritic cells are specialized for
antigen presentation and T cell priming
so that is they can take a naive t cell
that is totally unpolarized and expand
it polarize it in a particular direction
they also have a unique property in that
they in their immature estate they don't
have acidified n jism so they don't
digest they basically don't digest the
proteins until they get a non self
signal and so this allows me to capture
antigens in the periphery travel to lift
them and present whereas the macrophage
is much less capable that they
constantly digest all the time and
they're priming capability isn't quite
as good
right getting right to our next question
how our dendritic cells regulated sure
so um I guess the I think there's a
couple of ways you can trouble that
question one is the developmental
regulation of dendritic cells how do you
get more of them in the periphery and
there are common dendritic cell
precursors that have been identified in
bone marrow development most of their
dendritic cells that we think about in
the periphery or derive from that those
precursors and once they're in the
periphery they can then their activation
is regulated by pattern recognition
receptor engagement and so naturally the
dendritic cells will be will be normally
tolerogenic that is they'll when they
stimulate a t-cell may present
self-antigen to the T so it's a t-cell
recognizes it in order to become
activated it needs a second signal and
so that second signal is called
co-stimulation and northern polar right
into third signal which is derived from
cytokines interceptor so the naturally
self antigens presented without these
sort of cytokine signals or
co-stimulation signals which are coming
from pattern recognition so they would
terrorize those t-cells or energize
those t-cells so its regulation it's
dynamic regulation between immature and
mature state is through cell signaling
through pattern-recognition receptors
and inflammatory cytokine receptors
great thank you I think we just have
time for one last question is it
possible to activate the immune system
too much and produce autoimmune disease
oh there
yeah so the that that's a wonderful
question so we have seen that in in some
cases in our melanoma trials whereas I
defective of the therapy is the
induction of vitiligo when you begin to
kill the normal melanocytes obviously in
late-stage cancer this is seen as a very
good thing if you're killing those
melanocytes you're really killing on a
number of these really killing the tumor
cells with even greater efficiency
however this is something as we move
forward with more effective
immunotherapy things like the chartis
for instance or even in the context of
combination checkpoint activating and
inhibitory blockade we really have to
keep an eye on this more so in general
this is not something that we've seen
enormous it's not been a huge problem on
trials but as we become more and more
aggressive than the minute therapy we
need to keep keep an eye on these kind
of side effects thank you John wonderful
presentation lots of great questions
from our audience we are out of time I
would like to let our audience know that
this presentation is going to be
available on demand through November of
2016 you'll be receiving an email from
lab roots alerting you as to when that
is available for replay I want to thank
dr. John Connolly again for his time as
well as our sponsor today affymetrix
part of thermo fisher scientific for
making this webcast possible if we
didn't get to your question today we'll
definitely try to follow up with you
thank you for joining us today we hope
to see you again goodbye
you